president drop making an announcement
moments ago at a White House event
saying that he has been taking
hydroxychloroquine for about a week and
a half now the frontline workers many
many are taking it I happen to be taking
it I happen to be taking it contracts
accord hydroxychloroquine did the White
House doctor recommend that you take
that is that why your White House doctor
didn't recommend no I asked him what do
you think you said well if you'd like it
I said yeah I'd like it I'd like to take
it I want the people of this nation to
feel good I don't want them being sick
and there's a very good chance that this
has an impact so I'm taking the to the
zinc and the hydroxy and all I can tell
you is so far I seem to be okay the
president adding that he has had no
symptoms for coronavirus and is taking
the drug for precautionary measures this
news breaking just recently Greg let me
go to you first because you cover this
you drug for many weeks we've all read
about it we read we had the hopes for
the controversies about it and now the
president dropping this news into the
news cycle at about 4:30 this afternoon
I love it when he says yeah just very
casually I'm taking hydroxychloroquine I
would have told you sooner but you
didn't ask and that was perfect
again the most transparent president
ever and it's important to note that his
explanation was incredibly nuanced it's
about who you give it to and when he is
correct there are a lot of people taking
this who know what they're doing I've
talked to doctors many people that you
know and they were talking about it as a
prophylactic I don't know two months ago
he was also really dead on about that
last study which the media glommed onto
because they wanted that drug to be a
failure because they want Trump to fail
so they they played up this study in
which the drug was given to people who
are essentially near-death and so you
couldn't tell it what was gonna happen
if they were if it was too late when you
get this drug to people who can tolerate
it I don't think you can have any kind
of heart condition or arrhythmias and
things like that if you can take it
prophylactically
and and you might you its 40-year it's
fda-approved it's been around for
decades it's a say it's one of those
things that it's if it's available to
you and you can take it you do it
that's a prudent way of looking at it
diggin there was an FDA warning about
what Greg was talking about that if you
had any sort of heart condition you
should not take it I don't have the FDA
document in front of me but there are
also people who have conditions like
lupus that take this drug because it
does help them that is proven to help
them and they need the drug and a run on
this drug by people who are trying to
prevent getting coronavirus when we know
that actually you know washing your
hands and not touching your face is
probably the best way there is a concern
by people that have lupus that if
there's a run on this drug or doctors
are being pressured to prescribe it to
people who don't necessarily need it yet
I'm not saying that people just
shouldn't take it I'm not saying that at
all
but there is a concern by those who are
actually sick right if you're not sick
and your doctor tells you no don't take
it please listen to your doctor leave it
to President Trump for doing a giant
cannonball bloom right into the middle
of the news cycle a belly-flop is what
the wall street journal always calls it
because we got this incredible news on a
vaccine from moderna that they announced
early this warning that's why the market
was up so much that the immune responses
that some of the healthy volunteers who
were vaccinated in a clinical study that
in they was induced so they had a
healthy response to it and this is one
of the first vaccines that we're going
to hear about more daran up Pfizer are
working on vaccines Johnson & Johnson
Santa Fe just to name a few but this is
what's going to dominate the news cycle
and in terms of hydroxychloroquine there
have been some observational studies
about it and there was one that was done
in New York City that was released just
not long ago like a few weeks ago and it
basically found no impact from the drug
on I think that it was I will find it
but anyway it was there was no impact on
people who were
SiC not positive and not negative but
we're waiting for longer-term trials to
come out mm-hmm sir that news about the
moderna vaccine broke before the markets
open today one and it was one of the
reasons at the market I know what it
finally finished at but it was around a
thousand points up so you have that good
news on that vaccine that could possibly
be available for emergency use by fall
if everything goes well should caveat
that but this debate about
hydroxychloroquine somehow became a red
vs. blue issue and I can't imagine this
is not going to stir that up again what
do you think I don't know about red vs.
blue but I think it's it's a trumpet you
know it's all about him and what's
interesting to me in this breaking news
is I guess he's worried about getting
sick and more so than I might have
appreciated if he's been taking this for
a week and a half because that would
even be before there was concern about
vice-president pants and then there was
one of his aides and of course the vice
president's press secretary who tested
positive got vice-president didn't test
positive but he self isolated because of
his association contact with his press
secretary so I think the president is
worried and we know as Jesse likes to
remind me that the president is a
germaphobe but he didn't wear the mask I
don't know about the hand-washing
someone told me the other day that even
now the White House mess is closed I
think Dana you would appreciate that
that's pretty severe for people who work
at the White House that you have to do
takeout so I think that there's a sense
at the White House that things are maybe
more severe than the president likes to
tell the American people in terms of
worrying about this pandemic and to pick
up again on what dagen was talking about
there's good news about the vaccine but
if you look at the big Hospital studies
about the use of hydrochloric ween
chloroquine in New York City if you look
at the VA study if you look at academic
studies everybody comes back and says
there's no evidence that this is going
to have an impact a positive impact that
it has real efficacy in terms of
preventing you from getting disease but
apparently the President believes his
own spin
because you're not getting this from any
government or academic authority
well they they're getting a big job I'm
not saying that anecdotal evidence is
everything but anecdotal evidence does
exist Jesse where some people say that
if they weren't severely sick and they
took it it did help them get back but
the other thing jesse is that the
president says that he asked the doctors
the doctor said okay we can try it it's
like you're okay to try it we do know
one thing that the White House medical
doctors are responsible to make sure
that the president is in the best health
possible because he is the leader of the
free world and the commander in chief so
before with the you know everybody runs
away with this
like as a crazy town like I do think
that the doctors saying okay we can do
it we should have some confidence in
them yeah wands acting like the
president just announced he was making
meth in the East Wing like this is not
some like radical cocktail the
president's like I'll take some uppers
and some downers maybe a shot or two
like one the doctor of the White House
prescribed this like this is under the
administration and wait wait Jesse he
said he could do it he didn't prescribe
it I think okay well he administered it
wrong what's the difference he didn't go
to CVS to get it like you're splitting
hairs if the president asked the doctor
the doctor says yeah what's wrong with
that I mean everybody's acting like you
should have seen the media when he made
the announcement it was like when your
daughter comes home from college and
like at dinner she's like yeah I'm
pregnant
[Laughter]
and now you tell me like come on high
malarial drug that people take all over
the world that's been taken for what 40
to 60 years and it would also some it
doesn't work for others I think we're
making a little too big deal out of this
like we always do when it comes to
hydroxychloroquine I don't understand
why it's been politicized like it has